shawn mendes and justin bieber dropped
their collaboration monster today
they'll perform the track on the
american music awards this sunday
they actually pre-taped their
performance yesterday so they were
together
when the song was released
yeah so sean and justin co-wrote the
song with daniel caesar frank dukes and
the staff of the poet
all canadians noted nice and the guys
explained how the song was inspired by
their struggle with fame
this idea of perfection is not real
and it's like you just have to surrender
and kind of let go and be
and love and love yourself too and like
that pedestal
is not only what the society puts it's
like what i put myself on
and i kind of had to just be like you're
cool even if you like
missed some notes and stuff you know to
put it basically like in
in like a bigger picture it's not just
about singing it's about
everything in life like it's okay to
mess up growing up is tough in general
but growing up
you know not to say we have it harder
but it's definitely it's a different
circumstance growing up and having
everybody watch your every move i don't
know and having something to say about
it having something to say about your
relationships having something to say
about
everything so um yeah it's definitely
can be tricky but what's been really
cool is what we you and i've been
talking about is just like being able to
like come together yeah and be like you
know what we're not alone we went
through stuff that was really similar
and uh we can come together and it's
just i mean i think it feels so easy to
like feel
like like in your own bubble
you know for sure especially when you're
an artist because it like makes you feel
like the world's revolving around you
and then you realize like it's not and
you just
gotta like open up to people well as a
kid like when you're a kid you
you just you know you don't understand
like ego and stuff like you don't even
you don't understand it you don't
understand ego
we know about ego now for sure you know
when i said
who shawn mendes i really didn't know
like that was literally the first time i
ever heard your name
i swear i liked it i wasn't trying to
say i believe you
okay
he's lying remember that who is sean
mendez that tweet
yeah so so far the comments are not
great for uh the response to that
kristen says so shut up and enjoy your
money
so there is an element that you know
it's crimey river but but no in terms of
yeah dealing with the fame it's crazy
what they dealt with like tayden
like when did you start performing today
like
at what age oh i mean i started
performing probably when i was 12.
oh wow um you know but yeah i mean it's
been a while but i mean
you know the little amount of fame that
i have didn't come a little to a little
bit later
in my life you know i'm 37 years old now
so i think being able to have that
certain level of maturity and life
experience when i experienced
you know when i first got a hold of a
little bit of fame really really helped
me yeah
yeah you know i think that whole thing
of um you're talking about
being a little bit older when it comes
to you and so having the perspective of
you know life experience when you're
really young
it's a different story and i don't know
i don't i don't like those comments i
don't buy those comments
like oh just shut up and enjoy your
money like
you're not i don't think that that
person that wrote that comment is going
to really be able to have a sit-down
conversation with either those guys
so that they can understand the stuff
that they've had to go through
and the garbage they'd have to put up
with and the scrutiny that your life is
under
from a very young age before you even
understand what any of this
means it's like i don't know man growing
up under a microscope doesn't sound
um all that appealing you know no yeah
that's the thing i mean through your
teenage years you think of the stuff
that you do
when you're a teenager and both those
guys i mean i mean granted
shawn mendes has been pretty like
squeaky clean like he's done that really
really rightly he can't really compare
what justin has done and what shawn
mendes is like because shawn mendes
really hasn't done
anything that's got him any kind of
scandal along uh along the way of course
yeah bieber's had
a lot of issues a long way but yeah i
just think about you know as a teenager
you know having all that stuff just
broadcast out there is pretty crazy like
david do you identify with us too like
that idea of going through fame
yeah when you're in your team years do i
do you sympathize with that
that concept yeah i do
um i think being famous as a teenager
or as a young adult would be
terrifying to be honest with you
especially in today's day and age you
know i mean when i was growing up social
media wasn't
what it is today i mean people are
constantly people constantly have access
to you uh in the you know in the sense
that they can at you and
people can say that people say a lot of
negative things online which i think is
just part of a culture in general that
we need to
we need to change so that could be uh
particularly difficult on someone who's
a little bit younger and dealing with
fame
yeah i mean i know that i i hate it if
anyone says something
bad like if i read the comments or
whatever like that hits
that hurts a little bit but if you're
getting comments from like
around the world right and you've got
like
you know a million plus millions of
people that maybe don't agree with
how you or sorry i don't like something
that you've put out
or have a comment on like a mistake that
you've made like we all know people
growing up who have gone through their
ups and downs and had to learn how to
i don't know become who they are or
become someone they're proud of and if
they had to do that
again like under a microscope i don't
know how a lot of them would turn out